Well,
when you also have to look with
regards to the shadow ideas,
like you have to get in touch
with the depths of your anger.
You know,
lots of people are resentful
about all sorts of things.
They're resentful about Oh women and
they're resentful about men and they're
resentful about the patriarchy.
And there are resentful about the left
wing and resentful about the right wing
and the resentful about politicians
and they're resentful about like the
cataclysmic force of nature and its
ability to make people sick and,
and suffer.
And they're resentful about their own
inadequacies and about their bad parenting
and God like the list
is just bloody endless.
And that can make you very,
very angry.
That's part of that resentment and
cynical and bitter and dark and full of
fantasies about destruction and the
desire to bring things down and the wish
that everyone else suffered and the
desire to shake your fist at God.
And all of that's really dark.
You know,
Young said,
well the shadow of the human shout,
it extends all the way down to hell.
And you really meant that,
you know,
because all of the terrible things
that people are motivated to do are
associated with that shadow domain.
Like none of you are any,
none of you are saints in any likelihood.
You have a terrible capacity
for destructiveness.
And when you start to consult your
resentment and to see how angry you are,
it can terrify you to see
the depths of that anger.
Sometimes that'll manifest itself
in very destructive fantasies,
you know,
um,
which you might not want to
become conscious of because
there's so brutal let's
say,
and so aggressive that you can't even
believe that you generate them the nice
person that's you.
It's like so it's quite frightening
to open the door and see all that.
And that also associates you with
the entire dark shadow of mankind,
right?
The sate tannic element
of the human character.
And,
but it opens the door down
understanding as well too,
to understanding how people can do
terrible things because you could see
yourself as one of the people
who could do terrible things.
That's really useful.
You know,
cause then you,
well then maybe you start to be motivated
to be the sort of person who wouldn't
do terrible things.
You know,
if you can really come to terms with
the fact that that's part and parcel of
you.
It also is some perverse sense.
It's also a discovery of your own strength
though because you know if you have
that desire for aggression,
that desire for destruction and that that,
that ability to fantasize
in that aggressive manner,
it also means that you can incorporate
some of that into your speech and into
your actions so that you're
a lot more immovable,
right?
And,
and a lot more of a force to contend with.
It can give you some respect for yourself.
When you realize that you're a force
of destruction as well as creation,
then you're also more likely to treat
yourself with a bit more intelligent
caution,
you know,
to know that you're a part of you.
Is it ticking bomb in some
sense that could go off.
And so you,
you,
you try it a bit more lightly around
yourself and maybe you encourage people to
tread a bit more lightly
around you as well,
which isn't such a bad thing.
And all the people that I really admired
that I know have a clearly dangerous
side and you don't want to get,
you don't want to have that
activated any more than necessary.
But it's also what makes
them respectable and strong,
especially if they have
that under control.
So,
oh,
that's a bit of a dialogue
about shadow integration.
It's a very,
yeah.
Challenging undertaking,
you know,
to pull in that dark
side of your character.
And that would be all the things that
you've repressed or failed to develop as a
consequence of trying to be a harmless.
And
uh,
well let's say a harmless and
harmless citizen who looks
virtuous on the surface.
That's the union persona.
And you need that because everybody
needs a mask that they wear in public,
like a suit,
you know,
so that we can tolerate seeing
each other on the street.
We don't have to look right into
our depths every time we interact.
We need that persona,
but that has to be transcendent.
And the way to transcend that
is to integrate the darker
parts of the character.
They're very useful.
That aggression,
that's sexual demand,
for example.
All of that's very difficult to
socialize that competitiveness,
but unbelievably useful in
terms of force of character.
If you could manage it.